you don't hear yourself was that so well
hello everybody hello everyone and we
have another lecture today and some of
it is really a continuation of what
we've done this week and that's that
we've dealt with a couple subjects
primarily motion and we extended that to
the edge of the universe motion to the
edge of the universe trying to get a
glimpse of what it could possibly look
like
we covered a couple ideas one is the one
that I've got in the book and that's
that at the edge of the universe we have
magnetic fields in other words threads
under the Rope model they're swinging
around the galaxies and if there's a
galaxy right there at the edge that's
the last galaxy we would think that
there are some threads moving around and
that's gonna be the magnetic field but
the other thought that came in and that
we proposed yesterday and again none of
this is to convince you persuade you
recruit you in any way we're not trying
to convert anybody here we're just
throwing ideas so that it stimulates
your mind and one of the possibilities
that there are atoms out there like
loose atoms maybe hydrogen atoms very
possible
maybe hydrogen gas h2 out there and so
the question would in that case would be
well weren't they pulled in by all the
matter in the universe and as you know
under the rope hypothesis what you have
is when you have something which is very
distant from everything else what you
have in between is really a coaxial go
all the ropes the gazillions of ropes
act like a single one so it's like a
coaxial and if you visualize it that way
and again we're not trying to convince
you anything here we're just trying to
visualize what the edge of the universe
might look like if you visualize it like
that then what you're seeing is you know
one atom very very lightweight connected
by a single coaxial maybe it doesn't get
pulled in and you might have all this
matter out there which is buzzing around
I'd like to imagine as bees buzzing
around a hive maybe you can visualize it
as vapor as steam that covers like you
know the entire universe like a cocoon
it envelopes it and encapsulate the
universe and when I use the word
universe I'm referring to matter
okay so we're saying that maybe just
maybe if I were to travel to the edge of
the universe I would finally reach the
last galaxies out there and if I cross
the galaxies so that I get to the last
planet the last star if I could stand on
it whatever and I keep going I stand on
the last atom I'm a damn man what would
what would I see what would I experience
what what do I think would be out there
and what I'm saying is that maybe just
maybe there could be an atom further
down right beyond that galaxy maybe
there's a whole bunch of them out there
just kind of loose like floating in the
wind in a way and they don't get pulled
in because they're connected by a single
coaxial and they're so distant so
lightweight that maybe this body of
atoms or hydrogen gas or whatever is out
there maybe it's helium I don't know
forms like again a an encapsulation to
the universe and keep in mind that you
know as you get away from the center of
the universe if there is such a thing as
the center of the universe we always
think of it as maybe a spherical
universe maybe that's not the case but
you're relevant here for a second we're
saying that if you go to the edge of the
universe if you could do that if you
could see out there you know you
wouldn't be able to see anything if
there is no matter because of under the
rope
of light there would have to be at least
one atom in front of you for it to be
connected to your eye for it to be you
know torquing the rope and for you to
see it even if you could see atoms if
you had you know the vision of God so
that's that's another possibility and
obviously you know you are welcome to
propose alternatives but that's one of
the things that we kicked around another
issue again covering the issue of motion
we talked about motion this week what
the Greeks said what and how it
developed all the way to today and
motion is a tricky subject as I guess
some of you discovered yesterday we
always talk about the finite amount of
matter in the universe okay what we mean
by this is really that we could be if we
had the time and we're like god we could
count every atom in the universe okay in
other words what I'm saying here is the
amount of matter has to be constant in
the universe and that's only uh
something that comes strictly from from
thinking you know you don't need to go
out there and find out if if you can
count them all and you know I'm still
counting and maybe I'll stay till
eternity County yeah what were there's
no test you have to run to find out
right right you don't do any measurement
there's no tests required no experiment
how do you know this if you don't do a
test right and and and the way you know
it the way you can reason it out for
yourself is that if matter can't turn
into space and space can turn into
matter because one is vacuum one is
nothing the other one is something and
antithesis by definition then one can't
turn into the other one can't matter
cannot pop in from the void and void and
matter cannot turn into void that's one
issue the other issue is that if void is
that which has no shape there's no
boundary to cross so none of the matter
can leave space and go to another
universe or to another dimension
and no matter income in the universe is
a closed system it's the only imaginable
closed system and it is and here I'm
gonna say it the the tricky word in
perpetual motion and so one of the
issues that we discuss with my son
yesterday and I think and I'm just
summarizing essentially what we did
yesterday was that you know the motion
also has to be constant and this is
where it gets a little tricky and people
get a little nervous right hopefully
hopefully it gets you to think and again
the the analogy was a blob blob of water
to make it very simple you know you have
this blob of water that's all there is
in in space in the universe right that's
all there is in space and this blob is
moving one atom with respect to the
other within the blob but that's all
there is
well if that blob is moving one atom
with respect to another or one molecule
with respect to another we get a little
bit of a problem because the only way
you can stop it in the only way you can
induce more motion or feed motion to it
just from the outside otherwise from
within the the bulb this this blob I'm
not sure you know one atom is
influencing me another witch is
influencing the other and which
eventually influences the first so
they're all influencing each other
and it's like you know what would stop
them or or what would grind them to a
stop and what would get them to move
again or how can you infuse motion into
it and the only way I can think of it's
from the outside but if that's our
universe if that's what I just grabbed
that analogy if that's an analogy of our
universe and we still have a problem
because it means that motion within the
universe is also you can say constant
fixed countable I'm not sure what the
correct word here is but it gets to be a
monster because not only matter is
finite with quotations countable but
then the amount of motion you would
think like if I could weigh the motion
if I could somehow quantify it it would
be also constant
unless there's an outside force to do
that and what this means one more you
know the last part of this the corollary
is that every time you know I punch a
three I throw a rock or whatever that
motion gets spread to every atom in the
universe and whatever motions happening
out there is also somehow transferred to
us through the electromagnetic ropes and
this is harder to believe but you tell
me what's wrong with the reasoning okay
find out something finite being finite
matter in the universe being fine over
the universe itself being quiet it's
it's always kind of infinite everybody
no one ever pauses the question okay if
the matter in the universe or the motion
in the universe are finite like just so
much and there's no more what would how
would you explain the phenomena of
physics that we see every I think all
branches of ideas like quantum mechanics
or any religion anyone thinks about the
universe always thinks about the
infinite about that it doesn't end it's
a truth I mean I've heard of belief
system that talks about the finitude of
well yeah I think all religions favor
infinity and this might have to do more
with not so much with religion but with
what people have come up with in their
minds they look at the stars out there
the constellation in the old days
thousand years ago and they see so many
of them it just keeps going and going
going even today with our telescopes and
all this stuff we just see this infinite
that's my point and so from there we all
come up and say oh yeah it's infinite
you know whatever we means I don't think
anyone's ever brainstormed like what
does the unit what does a finite
universe look like you I mean it's
obviously fine it's the wrong word oh
yeah yeah
[Music]
and and again if if if mater can turn
into space or space into matter we have
to ponder we have to really consider a
finite universe we have to talk in terms
of that and if we talk in terms of that
then we have to talk about the edge of
the universe you're also talking about
infinite time in the sense they whatever
matter is there was always there and
always will be there yeah other one if
we're going to talk about time and again
we always relate time to motion but if
we're going to introduce this concept of
time you can easily say that if matter
is countable but motion has always been
there no one there was no like Plato
said you know no self mover or like
Aristotle said the unmoved mover if
there was no such thing then what we
have to consider and and just kind of do
it by corollary or conclusion or
whatever it's that motion had no
beginning and if it had no beginning in
terms of time you can say well it's
eternal it's perpetual incessant yeah
but incessant usually refers to the
future I don't know why you say well
that's incessant but nobody thinks of
incessant like it was incessant all this
time you know it's like incessant
typically it refers to the future
perpetual typically does as well but you
know again if we're gonna talk about
time it's gonna be perpetual incessant
eternal in both directions of time it
means it had no origin anyways we had a
couple of comments today and one of them
comes from monkey a dear old monkey from
from
the rational scientific method and I
pulled the C button friend where is he
pulled a couple of here is I pulled a
couple of his comments which were of
interest to me and he said the following
he says types of motion are constant are
constant the quality of motion varies so
he's saying the the types are constant
the quality is what varies he mentions a
couple types of roads of motions and he
didn't cover the whole gamut you know he
just said rotation torsion tension
vibration and pumping and he was just
giving examples okay he didn't cover the
whole I mean you know you had Plato he
talked about back and forth sideways and
up and down six motions plus rotational
motion okay well here you have a few
more I'm sure that if we were to use
descriptions like adjectives or really
adverbs to qualify motion we could come
up with a finite amount of those words
as well and there's only so much so many
motions I think that you can think of
and I would say that there under two
dozen I don't think you can come up with
more than two thousand yeah yeah motion
words yeah but a lot of them are
synonyms I live with him aren't right a
lot of them are synonym so you know I'm
saying like if we were to talk about
unique types of motion I think you'd
come up with a vocabulary maybe not
exceeding twenty four words but I don't
know you know someone's got to do that
you know that mental exercise and one of
the comments that struck me is the last
one here electricity doesn't cause
magnetism any more than magnetism causes
electricity and yes we agree but what
are we talking about by here what we
were talking about yesterday was saying
that you know I hit the tree and the
entire universe feels the punch
eventually that that
motion has to be somehow distributed
throughout every atom in the universe
from a conceptual point of view in other
words I don't think that it just dies in
the center of the earth where you know
gravity is is concentrated for the whole
planet I don't think it's just you punch
it goes to the center of the earth and
dissipates the motion dissipated I think
that gets distributed to every atom
that's out there in the solar system and
from there on to our galaxy or to other
star systems in the galaxy and from
there on to other galaxies I mean how
else are you going to conceptualize this
and again it gets back to the blob of
water if if any motion within the blob
is transmitted it relayed to other atoms
or whatever forms the blob and to it to
introduce more more motion you would
have to have something from the outside
and here we're saying electricity
doesn't cause magnetism magnetism
doesn't doesn't cause electricity but
what we were talking about and I just
want to put in the proper context is
that in order to produce magnetism you
need to get that energy that motion that
momentum that ghosts that spirit
whatever you want to call it we got to
get it from somewhere
you know you charge a battery and the
battery can then move a train or
whatever you know you're you're trying
to activate with your battery but where
does the battery get charged from or
from somewhere else and I think we're
all always transferring and relaying
motion I don't think you create motion
from one zip even like I'm saying you
know if I throw a rock with a little
ball here okay I've got a ball I throw
the ball okay and you say well you
created motion yeah I created motion
under the ordinary speech version of
motion but from a scientific or from a
physics point of view you know where did
I get the motion to to deliver it to the
to the ball and I get it from eating
food from resting from lot of sources we
call it you know
getting energy that's that's the
euphemism or the word that we use and
the question is where did we were you
know is is that a is that what gave me
the motion that's the question I think
we talked about this
giving motion or charging motion we get
dangerously close to how gravity was
explained in school for me at least when
you lift a ball for example off the
floor you're adding potential you're
giving it motion is about to use it
still it's a confusing issue because as
you showed the Newton cradle yeah
Newton's cradles cradle yesterday yeah
I've got here the ball the meeting let
me put that up through here but you show
the ball hitting the four balls in the
middle and they don't really move but
the last one does so balls the automatic
question asks is what was transferred
there yeah in other words here's the red
what are we talking you here's the ball
the red ball and it's transferring
something to that last ball we realize
that you know those black ball wouldn't
move if it wasn't for the red ball to
transfer the motion we'll caught the
motion for now we'll use it as a noun
through all these other balls that means
they all retransmitted they relayed the
motion to that last fall and so you know
as the ghost that we're talking yeah and
that's why you know people had some so
many problems with this throughout the
history of physics that they had to
invent works like momentum and energy
and you know what it transferred
transferred energy and you saying oh
okay and we left it at that but you know
if if if we're gonna say what didn't
transfer energy what did it transfer and
one of the subjects that came up today
also I I think it was Dave and he comes
up and he says I
I didn't quote his words here but he
said something along the lines that we
say that the rope delivers torsion or
you know what is what's flowing through
the Rope is torsion and again torsion is
a verb and so not a noun
not in physics and so we're saying hold
it what do you mean you transferred a
torsion or torsion moved or a signal
moved or a a what else gonna be a
disturbance or any word that you use
it's gonna be a verb and so what I'm
saying is and I put up here yeah yeah
but what I did here look I just let's
see if I can get him I put this wording
here let me make it a little bigger and
move aside and I said if someone asks
you what is light and under the Rope
model here right the answer is the atoms
torque we gotta talk baby like here okay
it might disturb you it might be very
disturbing speak but this is the way you
can have to say it no shorthand the
atoms torque the electromagnetic road
that makes sense because the atoms are
physical objects and they're gonna
torque right the electromagnetic rope
which is also a physical object now it's
straightforward what does the
electromagnetic rope do the
electromagnetic rope torques okay so we
have the noun followed by the verb the
e/m the electromagnetic is just an
adjective
okay so the rope torques and if someone
says well how come to the atoms detect
light well you say the rope twists the
last link of rope that forks at the
electron shell boundary okay
and again what are we saying we're
saying you know we put the noun first
and the verb afterwards like you know
you put the horse first and then it
pulls the cart only then can you make
sense of the of the statement now we use
short hands as long as we don't lose
track of what we're saying I don't see a
problem with short hands with
euphemism with ordinary speech language
introduced in physics as long as we
don't lose track of what we're saying
and so we say well yeah it transferred
the torsion or the torsion moved through
the rope no problem as long as you
understand what we're saying we're
saying that the rope thrilled in sits
you in place and because of that you
know the observer or the two atoms at
the end they sense that something moved
there and received some kind of stimulus
right at the electron shell what did it
receive two threads right twine threads
that are torquing that point on the atom
on the electron shell at the point where
they fork out right and so at that point
it received a tiny little stimulus and
again we get into a lot of ordinary
speech because it's it's just the
tendency it's the nature of this monster
what it did was simply receive a thump
okay it there there's a contact there
and and you can say thump you can say
friction you can say many of these words
are all verbs building into the ground
drill stays in place but the dirt goes
up so it's moving but it's not moving so
it has an effect on whatever it's it's
in but it's not really in it's moving in
place but well there's no torsion moving
inside the metal there is really what
you can do is yeah yeah drill bit is is
a good analogy for all this and me let
me pull this thing out
drill bit is a good analogy for this in
this sense let's say you have a drill
bit that is only made for wood okay
and by mistake you put it in your drill
and you go against cement well let's
assume that cement doesn't get tickled
even by this by this rotating drill bit
rotating drill bit right so you put it
against the wall and it doesn't do any
damage let's assume that the wall really
doesn't you feel it so what are you
doing you've got a drill that is
twirling in place not going in not going
out just standing there right it's just
turning around and I think that's how
you have to imagine the rope it's it's
kind of twisting in place and giving
that signal and motion whatever torsion
friction so many words we can use you
know to to talk about it but essentially
it's delivering motion okay and and
because it's not delivering like you
know when you get a pizza delivered to
your house or you get something you know
you get something in your hand and these
guys are not in a way delivering
anything in that sense but what they are
doing is providing more thread to the
atom and remember the atom is pumping at
that moment is also vibrating and you're
now providing two threads to that and if
the atom is moving it does absorb thread
and so you did deliver thread okay so
it's not like the atom did not get
anything ya got thread and we call that
that little motion and that tiny thumb
that it receives which is really more
thread we call that light in other words
that's the particle version of light
what goes through the Rope is the wave
version of light someone said light
travels as a wave and the parts and
arrives as a particle and he that's a
good analogy for what for the rope when
it comes out of the atom or when it goes
into the atom really it doesn't go or
come out in that sense but when it when
it touches that electron shell through
the torsion that's when we sense it as a
particle that's when we detect
in between what we have is just the
rotation of the rope and at that point
all we can say is that it's just a wave
in this case a torsional wave a
three-dimensional wave let's say we have
[Music]
anything beyond that Rodya gets more
common unit to boron or whatever you
forget it so you have two hydrogen atoms
when the two hydrogen atoms come closer
to each other huh the rope between them
does it gain frequency no not
necessarily unless they are stimulated
they move faster they pump faster but if
the hydrogen atoms are always the same
size right yeah they're both the same
size so when they come towards each
other than they eat the rope they don't
keep that size and huh they don't keep
the the rope that they ate it goes out
behind them yeah yeah okay so the extra
rope doesn't make it grow bigger yeah do
what's the relation between motion and
energy frequency between the two
hydrogen atoms do they does it does it
equalize as in all the the frequency
always stays the same if they move
faster than it changes a frequency but
again yeah yeah I just said because that
would see Weezer's yeah but it depends
on the rate at which it pushes against
that rope right if something stimulates
the atom as it's going you know sliding
like beat on an abacus right
sliding normal normally eating two
threads and releasing two threads okay
so it moves along the rope as it pumps
and as it vibrates now what happens as
it squeezes the waves in front of it you
know they open up normally if it's going
at a constant speed or whatever and it
just swallows thread which releases
behind it and so for for a given speed
it's going to have a
and frequency now you give a stimulus to
that atom let's say you increase its
vibration or its speed or whatever along
then you get the thread now it's moving
faster than what's moving before so nuts
eating thread at a faster rate and what
it does it squeezes kind of the rope in
front of it and that rope can only
absorb the slack by getting that you
know going at a higher frequency that
means shorter links okay you get more
links shorter names and that stimulus is
transferred to the other atoms that are
connected to it so yeah frequency is
affected by the speed so if you have
these two is the shock that they both
feel essentially I mean you have these
two beads on the abacus
yeah going towards each other the rope
between them is that the links are
getting squashed and squashed
essentially way more links more
frequency more energy between them when
they're coming towards each other
there's more something's gonna happen so
when they crash all all those links
essentially kind of ripple through the
atom and go out the height because the
the rope between them is always getting
fed through the atom all right the atom
yeah and behind behind yeah but you're
saying depending on the rate at which
they're going towards each other the
links between them might not have
sufficient time yeah yeah essentially
wideout be behind them so when the two
hydrogen atoms do clash all that rope
those between them which is always
taught essentially goes extremely fast
like whatever is left between the ropes
essentially goes extremely fast right
over the speed of light whatever you
want to say and that ripple going
through the atom is that like the crash
that the two atoms feel essentially when
I remember again wanted to simplify it
if what
punch a tree the reason there's any
vibration there is because these two
items came together in the Rope between
them was squash squash squash squash and
then like blasted through both of them
yeah and again we have to distinguish
what happens with the atom and what
happens with the rope these are two
different things in the case of bumping
we're talking about atom hitting at yeah
right and not only not always do they
merge like I was saying yesterday if the
two hydrogen atoms rotate in the same
direction day lurch and okay right yeah
and again remember that we're constantly
we're constantly touching things in
other words I touched the table
essentially I'm I'm hitting the table
but you know if you just say I touched
the table or I grabbed the glass what
did I do the atoms of my hand are
getting closer to the atom of the glass
okay that formed the glass so the ropes
there you know I'm pushing in there and
and that that motion is being absorbed
in a way by the rope because the rope is
there between the atoms to begin with
then all we're doing is sliding our
friends through the rope itself we have
a solution do I have to take a pill or
that's true that the energy or whatever
you call is the frequency between the
ropes between the two atoms sorry
the two atoms are coming towards each
other and the links between the roads
are getting essentially crushed okay he
doesn't have enough time to go through
the atom as they're coming towards each
other okay so you're increasing the
frequency increasing frequency more and
more what is the I guess this is the big
question this is kind of a mathematical
question so okay what is the average
torsion amount of ropes in the universe
or in the universe that because the
question of because that essentially
solves why there's only so much motion
because there's only so much torsion
there's only so many links yeah you're
saying you're saying that if
take all the ropes in the universe and
and of course the ropes are getting
longer in some case and not longer in
essence that they stretch but in the
sense that between any two atoms here
you know if I separate my hand from the
table now I'm creating more rope and
land between the two atoms yeah in other
words that not creative but in a sense
there is more rope between the atoms
okay when I get in my hand close to the
table there is less rope so we're
constantly you know making the ropes
between the atoms long and not longer
than in the sense that they get
stretched but in the sense that we have
more rope when I take my hand away then
when I put it in so we have to
constantly think of this under the rope
model that every time you get near an
object the ropes you know are getting
some shorter in the sense that you know
there is less rope between those that
not that you're squeezing them or that
you're stretching them and when you get
farther away you know you're the the
Rope re-establishes itself in between
the atoms that's what's happening
constantly and so again is the amount of
motion in the universe constants that's
my point you would think that it is if
there's essentially there's only so much
matter there's only so much frequency
[Music]
well frequency is motion it's again
motion is motion underlies but every
word but frequency is more tangible
there is between the completely if you
add all the torsion that was one of the
questions yeah the torsion and I'm the
measurable amount there if you were to
take the average of all the ropes in the
universe and you get a number there is
only so much torsion in the universe
does that is that the equals there's
only so much motion in the universe well
remember we we have fortunately
something that helps us in thinking
about this and that's that we have a
constant speed of light no matter what
you do with the weather ropes
between any two atoms in in the entire
universe the speed of light is constant
and no matter what you do you stand on
your head or whatever you can increase
the torsion on a rope and that means now
that you just have more more leaning you
increase the torsion you have more links
and and each link is is shorter okay but
what I guess what you're saying is you
pull that that slack from somewhere else
and again I think what monkey was trying
to say here is that mmm that maybe I
don't know I don't want to put words in
his mouth but maybe he was saying that
that's not true like you know what does
magnetism have to do with out or see
you're out twisting with magnetism like
there's one cause the other well no we
can have magnetism really we can't have
it with it without electricity but my
point here is that you know when when we
increase the frequency between any two
atoms for whatever reason are we pulling
that torsion from somewhere else
someone's got to suffer I mean otherwise
we're increasing torsion on every atom
in the universe and I doubt that's the
case I think that you know the God has a
very good accounting department and you
know whatever's over here is taken from
over here I don't think I don't think
you can increase the motion the
frequency the speed of light in the
universe somewhere you know the speed of
light is always constant that means if
if I'm gonna increase the frequency
between two atoms that means I'm gonna
have more links somewhere there's got to
be fewer links and a lower frequency and
and I'm not sure you can get away from
that I think the count has to even out
in the end
and that's what we have to keep in mind
then again you're welcome to challenge
that that's that's what it seems like to
me that that's the way it would work
right I wanted to deal with a subject
before I forget it because I thought it
was interesting okay okay
go with your question there now look
then let me get this in there because I
think it's important there's a battery
or living human being have higher
frequency between their a doze than a
rock have higher frequency between atoms
than a rock since yeah but a rock do the
same ocean
well again you can't talk I'm not sure
you can compare a rock which is standing
there you know it just received regular
frequency on us something stimulates the
rock or in some way if you just have a
rock there and all the atoms in the
universe converge you know all the ropes
from every atom in the universe converge
upon that rock unless you do something
you know to it nothing's going to change
in the rock but in the case of charging
a battery or whatever you are doing
something proactive yeah you're giving
it frequency essentially yeah and it's
storing this frequency this higher
frequency since it has energy charge I'd
have to think about it you know but I'm
not sure it's a good comparison but
there are ways of you can say like you
can take to charge batteries and compare
those one that has more charge than
another one and and find out what's
going on in there but again I'd have to
think about that you know find out
exactly what is happening inside a
battery I really haven't thought about
that you know also a human being
what
like in the human being the living human
being move and the rock can essentially
we have this frequency charged in us
somehow yeah yeah obviously even the
cell know if you take just the cell the
you don't have to take a human being go
go with the cell which is already quite
complex and the first cell that moved
had to have energy somehow well you
don't have to quotation if that's my
point it's exactly the frequency between
its atoms that's the question you
couldn't see between its atoms we have
to look at that it's I don't know
because remember a cell is very
compartmentalized and it's got its
regions they have to all work together
yeah it's it's got to have higher
frequency yeah and and it gets a lot of
that from the Sun but it also gets it
like depending if it's a cell from a
plant or a cell from you know an animal
you know there's gonna be a difference
as well but if you take even the simpler
one the the plant cell you know receive
the frequency from the Sun that's part
of its food and it does take some other
material that's surrounding puts it all
together and creates so-called energy
this the spirit that allows it now to
have self propelled motion and self
propelled motion comes from this extra
frequency yeah at least compared to a
rock extra frequency that it can store
essentially in its body or wherever it
stores that for yeah yeah and keep in
mind keep in mind when when dog dies you
know two seconds ago it was alive now
it's dead its atoms don't just stop all
frequencies
it just has maybe less frequency
especially in the key areas of its body
compared to when it was alive but it's
not like the atom stop stop pumping yeah
you know or stop doing anything you know
it's just the cell somehow dies and
maybe the key cells and that's why there
are animals dead anyways I'd have to
research the issue about the battery but
one of the things I wanted to mention
today and that's why I called it the
abstraction is the other day I meant
that was max born and he made a comment
let see if I can find it here he said he
said in the 1920 yeah I was thinking
about this today says since the
development of special relativity and
put it up here since the development of
special relativity theories using a
substantial ether fell out of use in
modern physics and were replaced by more
abstract models that's a statement
that's in the Wikipedia and it
references a book by Max Born written
1964 and they got me thinking because of
an article that was put in international
Science Forum today in in Facebook
because we have become more abstract you
know physics or science in general has
become more abstract we do a lot of
games today
that's quite abstract and people
sometimes have trouble distinguishing
between what they do you know for their
joysticks they're at home and the real
world out there and they sometimes
extrapolate it and think that they can
just take a lot of what they're
experiencing with the games and take it
out there and what is it that I'm
interested me about this is the
following is that if you look at the
definition of the word abstract yeah
okay says having there's several
definitions but these were two that I
pulled out having no reference to
material objects considered apart from
concrete existence and if you look at a
synonym unreal and if you look at the
antonyms now this is interesting
physical material real what are we
saying if we take max borns notion here
that we went into up stretch and we're
saying we've got no way from physics
because physics is physical physics
deals with objects and these people are
saying look we become ever more abstract
so they went in the opposite direction
of physics and you might say well you
know we have to use some concepts to
talk about physics but that's not the
point the point is that physics is done
with objects
okay what these people are doing they're
doing physics with concepts they're
moving energy they're moving masses
they're moving time they're bending time
they're talking about fields all these
are concepts and and they've long ago
stopped talking in the way Galileo would
talk for example Galileo would say okay
let's roll some balls down this inclined
plane and let's study you know the
rolling of balls and the effect of
gravity on balls and and that's not what
we do today today the the armchair
physicists over there at Canberra jor
Harvard he sits back and what he does is
say well if I move the energy in this
direction and then the forces over here
and then we have this mass they're
pushing around they're juggling as I say
they're juggling concepts in that sense
it's become abstract and what that has
done is taken it away from physics
because physics is about objects as you
can see here Anthony's physical material
real definition having no reference to
material objects so if we've gone like
mr. Bourne says in the direction of
abstraction all they've done is gotten
away from physics and the article today
was very interesting let me just quickly
put it up here if I can find it where is
it
here's the death I caught the death of
physics this came out of what I think it
was a blog because I'm you know these
articles are not very popular so when
someone gets it puts it up there so oh
look at this guy saying yeah but it's
one guy nobody listens to so just keep
that in mind and the title was
theoretical physics maybe pair
paralyzing real scientific breakthroughs
okay so it was a very catchy title came
out I think three or four days ago and
here are some of the comments there were
statements that I pulled out of their
theoretical physics has made some
amazing headlines over the past few
years looking closer though a disturbing
trend starts to appear the problem is
modern physicists seem to be more
interested in searching for math
equations and entertaining ideas than
exploring concrete reality by immersing
themselves in the abstract world of
mathematics physicists again
mathematical physicists have lost sight
of reality and begun indulging in purely
theoretical ideas like the existence of
multiple universes the current
establishment could benefit from a new
perspective right now it sounds like
we're right for a revolution yeah right
on the money of course but again nobody
reads articles like the or agrees with
them but it's an interesting article in
that sense because I think it's right
we've gotten into abstractions and an
abstract is the opposite of physical in
in this context what we're saying is
abstract is non material whereas physics
is material so if you're going into
abstractions that's the direction in
which we're going all we're doing is
getting away from physics very
interesting irony that comes up out of
all that I thought at least any comment
there my dear son how do you solve
someone's lifelong
attachment to a distraction well I use a
baseball bat you whack over the head you
try to see if this you can dispel the
hypnotism that's how you do it what
exercises would you recommend for
someone who is so deep into black holes
or moving masses how could they start to
get their head out of abstraction and
into the real world I'm trying to find
that question if anyone knows please
write to me you know 1-800 what I have
no idea it's like it's like trying to
convince a born-again Christian that
there's no God more or less that's
that's what you're up against these
people have gone to college they've been
brainwashed to exhaustion on all these
terms all these concepts they've heard a
lot of the arguments they finally became
convinced of that and you're not gonna
go in there and overnight and convince
them you know not not to change their
mind but to even ponder to even consider
something different to think outside the
box as it's called they're just too much
into it and I know because I've had
discussions with some of the
professionals out there physicists and
so on they call themselves physicists
and there's no way they're thinking and
their brains function a different way
because they've been drilled to
exhaustion with all this nonsense
I think it's akin to trying to convince
a normal person earth is flat most
people won't even consider the idea at
first I threw it aside but I remember
one day I actually sat and thought about
it for a long time I don't think a lot
of people do that like they don't even
consider it yeah yeah I think the same
brushing aside of kind of ridiculous
ideas applies to any ideas once you've
been indoctrinated once you have a good
a good quote unquote theory for anything
then you kind of brush aside other ideas
much more quickly because you already
have one yeah but it's a
one of the issues that we come across
here is that people have have officially
those who have gone to college and taken
courses in physics or are majoring in
physics they've been taught as as like a
foundation that we can't go back to
classical physics so anybody who brings
and says look I can I can understand how
the universe works immediately they shut
you of this it's impossible who do you
think you are god that's that's the
attitude they they have they have
rejected classical physics which was
again things like what Aristotle I'm
sorry yeah Galileo would have done your
role balls down an inclined plane or you
know some kind of experiment even Newton
you know he did quite a few experiments
in his basement that's how he found out
many things about light he just ran
light through he did the Newton's hair
experiment you know which later on Young
is going to explain but the double slit
he did he sent light through a prism so
he was aware of a lot of these things
because he did experiments but nobody
does these things anymore you know
everything of that nature is more or
less than theoretical in a sense that
you go to college and someone just
explains to you you know Newton and this
and found out that and and you don't
have to repeat the experiment because
Newton already did it so why are you
gonna do it maybe you might do one new
experiment here another one there but in
general there's no hands-on it's it's
all that stuff is covered like swiftly
like saying you know don't pay attention
to any of that because that's how we
started and this is where we are at now
and then you jump directly into quantum
mechanics and so to get a guy like that
and trying to get them back into
classical physics you know rational
physics as I say dealing with objects I
cannot imagine that kind of revolution
so what this individual said here in
this article saying you know we're right
for revolution yeah we're right for
revolution but I'm not sure this is
going to be like what
Martin Luther did you know but 500 years
ago it's not gonna be like that it's uh
it's much more difficult today because
on the one hand we have internet that
which is good but on the other you're
swamped with so much noise out there
that you know you can't get people to
even listen to what you're trying to
propose or as an alternative and again
you're now talking about convincing
people you're talking about look here's
another idea for you to consider people
won't even consider it because they've
already made up their minds and I think
that's probably the problem here anyways
I thought I'd mention that that we've
gotten away from from physics and we've
gone into abstractions and so that's a
serious problem the other one I just
want to restate that the Rope torques so
we when we talk about torsion you have
to be careful with the language you
don't want to say that the rope transmit
torsion that's not a good way of talking
it's okay as long as you talk to people
who are who understand you know really
what you're saying but when you're
talking to a new guy out there or
someone who or a devil's advocate you
got to say the Rope torx noun followed
by verb and and the other thing I wanted
to say okay I went there there's another
issue here the final one and that's the
definition of torsion and here are some
of the synonyms and you have twists that
that more or less matched the word
torsion you have twist braid coil what
is it curly Q helix spiral twine wind
like winding something and vortex you
know that a lot of the people in the
electric universe talk about the vortex
even people who are not part of the
electric universe they like the word
vortex and they don't realize for ticks
is a verb you can't say dub for tex this
the vortex that you can't say
you can say that this thing vortexed
that way you can use the word Portage's
but they're not aware of that there's a
lot of modification of version spiral
water yeah and again we have to be
careful with how we use some of these
words because they are verbs and as long
as you don't lose track of what you're
saying then you should be okay but if
you talk to a new person person who is
not into this you may you know they they
might get very confused because they're
saying what do you mean you know the you
know the torsion traveled through the
rope I thought you said you could use
verbs and so that's where you gotta say
no the rope torques while we're talking
even here that you're trying to use yeah
and so again be careful with the
language that's one thing we have to say
and and it comes back to this issue of
motion when you have Newton's Cradle
what did it transfer ultimately yeah it
underlies all motion in the universe in
that sense you're right but remember an
atom vibrates and it receives that
vibration in two ways one through the
road and the other one with collision or
atom against atoms delivering motion
through the urging motion I think all
we're talking about is how many links
are between atoms I think there's more
involved in that one ball he's the other
is all that roll
between the all those links sorry not
the rope but the links that shoot
through one item let's say they're all
hydrogen atoms like beads and shoots
through one and they're all close
together so that a burst of links go
quickly through all of them until it
finds somewhere to to release the extra
motion or yeah yeah I guess in a way it
is because if one atom bumps another
atom it bumps it away so it goes away
but somehow it reflects in the ropes
that are connected to it which transfers
that motion also to atoms which are not
connected to it so in that sense yeah
you could say the means of transferring
motion is the rope no matter whether
it's bumping or just sending energy you
know sending the torsions through the
robe or the ropes torquing one way or
the other what you're doing is
transferring all motion through the rope
the robot is the the Rope is the highway
system the rail system of the universe
but I think instead of saying it
transferred motion better with things
that transferred links or transferred
frequency is more visualizable instead
of giving it a ghost that it gave you
can actually see like links like I could
probably show that and you can show it
on the screen
because you don't saw on the screen yeah
where all those links went right wound
up be nice to make a little video or a
little presentation or something like
that when you use where you show that
two atoms collide and what effect it has
under the Rope model where that motion
is distributed through all the ropes to
at least the immediate atoms that are
around me essentially what we're saying
is the universe is in gigantic windup
toy all that wine is who wound it up the
Albert is been wowed no one works on
this good winding
that's what energy is yeah yeah yeah in
a sensitive but then the issue here
again is that I think what's important
about is that the Rope system is the
highway system of the entire you know
that is the highway the road system the
train tracks of motion motion goes
through there but again when we say what
was transferred well what was
transferred is always it's always at sea
it's always you had 300,000 kilometers
per second what changes the only thing
that changes is the number of links and
how short they are how long they are and
I'm suggesting that if the blob analogy
that my son came up with the other day
is is a good analogy then what we have
is that the motion is constant someone's
got to suffer the the accounting has to
be kept in check in other words when you
have more links over here and lower
frequency in other words each link I'm
sorry we have more links and shorter
links somewhere else we have the links
are longer and the and there are fewer
links between those two atoms somewhere
someone's got to suffer I don't think
you can avoid that under the rope model
but again maybe you have a different
perspective and please let us know we'll
see you on Sunday folks and we'll if we
haven't covered something please raise
the issues then motion and the edge of
the universe
we'll see you that bye-bye